hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cuphead so we've
gotten a couple bosses we are slowing
down in our pace but I'm not gonna let
that get to me because I owe that
Wolfgang
oh it's taking ten notes to express two
notes worth of music he has no
conception of what I mean by more or
less is more I know you agree with me go
convinced that tenured o'clock he won't
listen to me anymore alright whatever I
don't know what you're talking about
rugged Ridge I'll get to whatever he was
talking about later because I right now
have to take care of rugged Ridge
alright you know what
oh I don't like that well then that
boomerang thing ain't gonna no way
alrighty then this is cute oh hey come
on now not fair not fair not fair not
fair not fair man half of me getting it
this is me not knowing what to expect
well god damn it you get you you and
your aim whoa oh hey whoa way a big guy
big guy big guy big guy we got bigger
come on now how about this oh yeah that
did the number on him who else is here
nope doesn't giving whoa how do you are
you supposed to get that one a name
worth it I don't need the money that
badly
I brought again died anymore why whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa slapper
all right oh wow
well I wasn't even close some wasn't
even closer this one's gonna be a tough
one yeah here we go full HP and ready to
go down the elevator of doom you're a
beggin your a bigan why are you begging
don't be a bigan be a Smallin no those
dragons ain't gonna even get a chance I
already killed your parents I guess
whatever you want to call your dragon
buddy okay you're dead
like I just spun into a world and it'll
instantly whoop
well bye guys wow that's that's peculiar
I don't like the look of that
man I love this gun so much precision is
key indeed nice discus throw No why
aren't they affected by the lion roar
same spray Steuben huh oh you know I'm a
switch cuz I have a funny feeling that
I'm gonna be bone over by some stupid
anytime soon now oh man my trigger
finger it's getting hurt my trigger
finger is really triggered here no no
none of that none of that none of that
no none of that
yeah that's right no no I was a wall and
then I lived up for nothing though
everything and I like to look at you
okay well this is this precarious I
really don't know I really don't like
this now well you got the sassiest walk
I wish I could look at it but god damn
you are one sassy piece of poop ain't ya
you're lucky I got precision jumping
skills because I am just absolutely
shredding this obstacle course here oh I
had to talk I had to open my big
flapping flapper gums and goof around
with me being stupid why did I do that
why did I - into nothingness when I was
perfectly okay where I was alright
whatever I mean oh you died ah you fell
and died everyone's sad except they're
not so just die okay alright we got
these results pretty good that took way
longer than it shut up but that's
alright and we did absolutely terribly
but you know what Grady see I'll take it
that's average I'll take it consistency
is the real deal in this endeavor a barn
get to bond get to buying it ah look I
met stairs I'm so happy about the stairs
and I mood what do we got there who's
gonna be a dick to me alright let's see
what's going on I'll see how it goes and
then I'll judge what weapons I need oh
don't like this guy already
don't like him already all right whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy there was no need for
slap aah you hate that and slap okay yes
okay and slide whoa oh [ __ ] lives right
in front make face I don't know why that
took so long
monk oh no I punched whoops Wow I didn't
even see that thing I don't know how I
didn't see that thing but I didn't see
that thing that's crazy
whoa whoa I didn't I don't know why I
ran into that that was not that was not
what I was opposed to be doing yeah well
I got this I got this guys provide a
choice I'm gonna take out the top laser
cuz it just makes it easier for me
because this is the this pure slap of
energy and that's oh why did I run into
that though impatience twitchiness there
you can blame whatever you want that's
what that was all about all right you're
gonna go down buddy you have no choice
in the matter
haha got your head go hey whoa hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa there really is no
need sir sir sir sir sir sir Sir sir
oh no you're a heart your poor heart Oh
done whoa that I didn't realize that
thing had such an explosive radius oh
whoa hey where'd dad go that's no good
you can't get me I'm too fast for you
you can get me
oh wait Oh what's this Serbs it dub see
that was no good man those guys are dead
ah knock you out of sky you douche ball
dogs so shocked out damn I am oh oh oh
boy hell I'm slapper whoa I didn't see
that
why did not see that big wall I didn't
see that big wall happening alright
whatever whatever you think you can get
me the answer is no ha ha ha ha ha ha
slapper
also wasn't paying attention to how much
slappa energy I was withholding
oh no your whole operation got Tucker
[ __ ] well what is that what is that
what is that what is that what is that
that's not right that doesn't seem right
don't do that don't do that don't do
that come on don't do that ok here we go
here we go oh god I forgot that thing
why how did I forget that I just saw
that oh whoops that was my bad that was
my bad that was totally my fault God but
I only got one hit left side I don't
think there's gonna go very well for me
yeah there he is
there is Ben oh god damn it why does
this guy have it out for me by the way
he seems like a perfectly Noble
scientist yet he's still he's making
such a concerted effort to try to beat
the [ __ ] out of me and I don't take much
too kindly to that
oh he mad oh oh god damn you
god damn you damn you damn you sir Oh
oh no no no no no I forgot I almost
forgot about that
okay all right and I'm gonna get him
watch this watch this watch this watch
this watch this boom baby
oh you thought you had me the answer is
I had you naive this guy is not joking
around here
there he goes though okay all right
doing pretty good doing pretty all right
fancy slaps [ __ ] well God is so hard to
see with all the [ __ ] in my way oh [ __ ]
well I've really boned this one up okay
here we go gun Avigail Oh whoops well
totally wasted that one every every
chance I had a victory has just gone out
the window oh whoa whoa I was not paying
attention I did pretty good there okay
he's not so bad he's not so bad once you
get to know him he's really not so bad
the bullet hell
part at the end there is probably the
easiest face in my opinion when again no
one cares about my opinion so what does
it matter
oh why forgot that guy shot energy beams
out of those whoa I Y blanked completely
on now and those that was so bad of me
that was the worst thing I've ever done
alright let's see let's see let's see
let's see let's see let's see let's see
let's see let's see what you lap let's
see what you got buddy come on do you
think it better than me huh what time to
prove it buddy here comes the bomb Oh
can't dodge that [ __ ] whoa I'm too
close I'm too close I got way too close
for comfort there yeap slap whoa okay
that was an almost bad maneuver why are
you laughing so much your precious
diamond is just exploding all the value
off of it yes he wasn't so bad once you
really got to know him yeah you get to
know him intimately because apparently
it lost his clothes right at the end
there but not so bad now the hardest one
I've ever had
yeah the bullet-hell part is easy like
just getting to that part it's just the
hard part that's all it is to it
oh yeah me plus okay move it get out of
my face I love bolt hills by the way
bull Adele's are my fav my jam I can do
bullet hells all day what is that for a
second doctor cows robot well is it the
robot soul that's that's collected
because that's not so bad then so Ludvig
has been feeling your mugs with his
lesson Morris really keep talking to
that fool and soon nothing will sound
all right to you
do you see I didn't burn you all right
whatever you say man what do we got here
dramatic fanatic all right Phil the Fiat
ah I'm down for a little theater
whatever you say
oh god it's so weird going from like not
doing the not using the the ship oh
that's weird
hey what is your objective here Oh
laughs here art oh [ __ ] god damn it what
do you do
Ricky you frigging Dancy pants here stop
dancing and stop dodging my shots whoa
ah [ __ ] ah man I'm just not ready for it
oh I see oh boy okay that's not good
that's not good is oh boy that's not
good
something Bad's gonna happen oh [ __ ] I'm
not gonna be able to hit her with this
am i baby why do you have a baby oh wow
slap myself right into death there okay
stay away from center stage let me try
the other weapon I don't think this I
don't think the charge one's gonna be
best for this that's right are we all
having so much fun err I bet I'm not
okay where do you how do you away that's
my big question here of all the things
and polarities that I see around here
that might be the weirdest okay bye see
ya have a good day it's best to safety
curtain oh boy breathe deeply
what about me talking about me what
about being all right well whatever you
say these aren't oh whoa whoa okay all
right well that's new oh boy all right I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to hear
ya but good luck to you to survive this
oh boy ah oh [ __ ] yeah I went right into
that oh boy Wow
okay it's getting dicey oh [ __ ] god damn
it I keep oh I keep forgetting that she
can throw her fan oh god I thought she
was going back saves ah [ __ ] that was my
bad those my bad for being a fool today
okay that's what you see that you see
the curtain pieces going up that's the
only time when she actually goes so I
don't need to be early about it I just
need to be less stupid about it which is
a problem for me because I I have a
tendency to be extremely stupid about
everything that I do
me what me what me what what are you
talking about me bah-bah-bah-bah
bah-bah-bah-bah bah-bah-bah-bah
oh no you're mice I want to slap of that
Oh again I slap it myself right into
damage so stupid
so stupid so stupid to me oh these
frickin mice why do you have mice whoa
whoa there's a why the bottle the bottle
there's a world where you go to the the
mouse drop placement to help you out I
think that's what you got to do okay
okay okay okay all right lady lady lady
lady I don't like being there okay good
good thing I got that invisibility dodge
like really that invincible dodge has
made this so much easier I don't even
oh hey I think didn't it like reduce my
damage a little bit but even so it's
it's so worth it okay here we go second
phrase [ __ ] God again not paying
attention to anything I'm doing oh the
fan on the ground baby baby
[Music]
alright come on you [ __ ] come on you
[ __ ] come on you [ __ ]
come on [ __ ] come on you [ __ ] come on
come on come on and I'm just I'm not
saying to try to be sexist by anything
I'm just like that's my go-to adjective
to describe people don't read anything
into that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] okay here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go here we go here we go here we go
is the one there's one there's one there
boink who's gonna be the one I'm not
gonna not gonna try to not gonna try oh
god I did I did the exact thing I said I
was gonna try to do but so skewed the
damn you and your rat's sack of [ __ ] oh
oh oh you thought that you could know
how to avoid me well the answer is Oh
your husband so sad putting whoa hey
whoa whoa that's weird
meteor what does that mean I don't know
there's a big wave what is what good
thing I got this wow this is super weird
lightning okay all right Wow okay all
right well you know I'd do a lightning
again well you know yeah they say about
lightning striking twice the same nice
yes I think I can walk under you can i
yeah I totally can yeah oh god damn okay
oh that's nice Mario bro Oh No okay all
right final phase I don't know if I'm
gonna make it I only got one life left
one hit left and I'm guaranteed I'm not
gonna whoo oh I don't like this what are
you doing
Rose oh the roses are deadly okay that's
oh [ __ ] Oh baby oh getrekt erecting the
hacking back Oh baby boom baby okay all
right that is all the time I got for
this episode thank you everybody so much
for watching I love this game so much
it's so fun it is ludicrously fun and
I'm getting better at it so I'm not
great yet but I'm getting better at it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]